what is his post-presidency look like if
you could guess
ah i mean you gotta look you buy into
this [ __ ] he's gonna be like this big
you know figurehead in the republican
party i don't know what
no he look he might still run for years
he's crazy enough he might but either
way he's either going to live in trump
tower
or he might i don't want like fall for
like the the griff that like oh they're
going to actually arrest them and do all
this [ __ ]
but they might and like he might be
smart to get out of here and go like to
somewhere
with you know less extradition i don't
think he's gonna do that i don't think
biden
wants that and i also don't think i mean
i i don't think they're gonna do that i
think that
i think he decompresses
yeah sobers up not from booze he doesn't
drink or any of that but i think sober's
up from the idea like
i'll probably move permanently to
mar-a-lago i think i'll move firmly to
marlock i think what'll kill him is
not going to those rallies i think those
rallies were everything they were they
never had
before you never had those rounds no
he's like it seemed like
he was always a grifter and like a car
he became a god yeah
but he never had the like in person like
[ __ ] like the crowd
well he never became a god and you know
me and you touched on this
years ago the the greatest thing about
trump i think or the magic was the
implausible becoming the plausible right
the idea that he was winning
the idea that he won the idea that he
was the president
it's a fairy tale right it's a fairy
tale it's an american fairy tale right
now when a guy like him is not the
president yeah
it's almost like what are we doing you
know
you seem more and more like a crank and
it's not
fun yeah because the crank is no longer
the president
like you're just a guy yelling oh yeah
and and people are kind of going to be
like how are we going to be invested in
this because there's
you know well like i don't think he does
trump tv
i don't think he does he does think he's
running in 2024. he does think that he's
not gonna but
he thinks it now i mean like he'll
probably be dead by then like he's
look he i really do feel like he he
what's keeping him going is like
adrenaline and like he's taking a lot of
bad role
allegedly uh and look i'm just saying
like he doesn't seem
if troll if trump we've always
remembered how like some of these guys
these deep state guys always seem to
live and they eat the good food and
they take care of themselves and then we
have a guy like this who's just eating
trash every day
he's just taking drugs though it's like
but maybe it's the greatest drug is
narcissism like we realize
maybe we realize that's the ultimate
survival nobody wants to hear that right
but the ultimate survival mechanism is
to just be a soulless narcissist for
your entire life
you know like that's just gripping to
life that's the way to survive
everything from covet to [ __ ]
everything he's just gonna
he's gonna get feather right uh he's
gonna play golf every day
like it's not gonna be remarkable he's
gonna play golf and get fat
uh fire off a tweet every now and then
he'll probably tweet all the time he'll
probably be cranked out
yeah and people are gonna ignore him now
yeah it's just gonna be
like we're gonna remark how
we're gonna at one point say wow we
underestimated how much damage he could
still do
well let's just say that at some point
yeah i mean he will do he will
cause something to happen i mean maybe
i don't know i'm really wondering what's
what's that still from
i don't know these are my work makes me
have them the butcher shop i work at
oh yeah has been screen savers on my
computer i mean
i just don't know but you know
biden and kamala man they're gonna
i mean they're gonna put people in jail
you think oh
i don't know what they'll do i think
we'll probably go to getting into a war
soon
we might need that you know we need that
we're not getting out of this economic
thing without a few little skirmishes
that's the but here's the problem we
don't get out of
a war that's the myth and it's not i'm
not sure what the henry haslam like
broken window fallacy yeah that's a
different thing
we've had perpetual war for like 60
years now 75 years
you don't get like it doesn't really
juke the economy anymore like it worked
in world war ii because we didn't have
all the stuff
right we had to build it now we like we
keep it it does juice economy for
certain sectors right so
i mean look here's the thing we have
it's kind of getting it backwards
the economy is set in such a way where
you have to fight wars every 10 years or
so just to deplete the stock
pile so that you can the these companies
who run the economy this is why
that's what i mean we got it you got to
you got to play that's just to keep the
status quo
you got it it's reverse it's reversed
you gotta play to pay
it's not pay-to-play you got to play to
pay
and i think we got to play a little bit
so we can pay later i mean i don't know
but
that's just to keep that sector from
imploding that's not even to get like
going